welcome everybody to another video made
exclusively for youtube uh in this video
i will be
doing something that most streamers do
very often and
in general most chess enthusiasts uh and
you among them are probably familiar
with which is
the puzzle rush feature on chess.com now
puzzle rush
is a type of tactics trainer um that
basically took the world by storm when
it was released
i would say approximately a year ago and
the concept behind puzzle rush
is very simple you get a certain amount
of time
to solve as many problems as you can you
have three strikes and the problems
increase in difficulty
now as puzzle rush got older
chess.com came out with a new feature
called puzzle rush survival
which essentially gives you unlimited
time the puzzles still get tougher and
tougher with each one you solve
correctly
and once again three strikes uh means
that
the run is over and while it might seem
that
one could get an infinite score the
problems at some point get
so incredibly hard that even with you
know hours and hours spent it it still
is very difficult to solve them so
um a lot of you know a lot of streamers
a lot of grandmasters
do puzzle rush on stream and while it
can be impressive to watch them solve
problems very very quickly
the instructive value of their
run is i would say at best very limited
because most people are simply not
following what's going on on the board
and they are not explaining how it is
that they're finding
the things that they're finding so let
me give you an example if i were to
solve
if i were to do a three minute puzzle
rush uh run
and i wasn't trying to be instructive
this is what it would look like
as you can see i'm about to solve some
problems very very quickly
and i'm not going to do an entire run
here but you can see that i am
simply going for speed here i
mouselipped and etc etc so
i will not do this let me get three
wrong so i can restart
i'm gonna go back into puzzle rush here
what i'm going to do in this video
is actually walk through the puzzles
very slowly
and explain exactly how i solve each
part each puzzle so
i'm going to do survival mode up until
40 puzzles are solved
and then i will make a separate video
about the tougher puzzles which
generally start at approximately puzzle
number 40. so
i'll spread that into two videos and in
this video i'm going to go through
every single puzzle i'm going to explain
exactly what i see
and in general i'm going to try to
provide sort of a high level guide
for tactical problem solving so without
further ado
let's get started now the first couple
of problems are generally very easy and
they usually feature either
a quick checkmate or you know capturing
a piece or something like that so when i
look at this position i immediately see
that black's king
is hemmed in by his own pawns that's a
weak back rank nothing is defending that
back ring so we can give a check
and we can take the rook with checkmate
now the second problem what i
immediately see is this pawn on b2 when
you have a fiance bishop
you have to see everything that that
bishop pressures even through an x-ray
and this knight on f6 can easily be
uh gotten out of the way and what's
going to happen then is that black is
going to have two attackers on that b2
score which is exactly what i'm going to
do i'm going to take the knight
and then i'm going to take the b2 pawn
here i'm simply going to count the
attackers on the e8 rope we have one
attacker and two attackers now notice
that the rook on e1 is still in his
hacker
through the x-ray now the concept of an
x-ray is very very important
and it allows us to understand that even
though the queen is the only piece
that's currently making direct contact
with the rook
the rook on e1 is still indirectly
pressuring that square because after we
take
the rook is in fact going to be
defending that square takes
rook takes c8 we're upper rook now this
is an end game
but that doesn't mean there are no
tactics in fact end game tactics
i actually made a video on that now here
we see the king on g3
being incredibly active the king on g1
is completely hemmed in
we have rooks doubled on the f file
which means that rook f1 is going to be
checkmate
because the stroke on f8 is guarding
that square and as we just discussed the
king has nowhere to go so we're going to
go and deliver that checkmate
here uh the first thing we often have to
do in these types of middle game
positions is check for hanging pieces
you know and there's no rocket science
behind this i just look across the board
i scan the board
and i notice any and all pieces or pawns
that are hanging now black's queen is
hanging which means he has to move it
but you'll also notice that the e3 pawn
is hanging and that's actually going to
be a fork
which means that not only do we win a
pawn we also win a knight
now this position is very interesting
because we're currently pinned
so you know this knight on e5 might seem
like it's toast if we defend it with a
move like f6
well white could get his bishop out and
pressure the knight even further so it
doesn't seem like we gain anything from
that
but loose pieces drop off is one of my
favorite
acronyms and one of my favorite
abbreviations that helps us see a lot of
tactics the rook anyone is undefended
that is why it's so important to connect
to rooks and because it's undefended it
is prone to discover
checks what can we do we can give a
check with the knight
exposing the queen's attack on the rook
so we actually
you know the hunted becomes the hunter
and the queen takes e1
now it's clear immediately from this
problem that both kings are in grave
danger which means
most probably we need to operate with
checks the first check that i see is
queenie one check
he has to block with a bishop and while
we can't take the bishop in that
position because the king is defending
what we can do
is ward off the king by giving another
preliminary check on d2
the king has to go back to b1 and then
queen takes d1 is of course checkmate
another double rook end game faces us
next now
first thing i notice is the b2 pawn this
is a huge asset for black
but we have to act very very fast
because given an opportunity white's
gonna go rook a4 rook a2 and he's gonna
surround and take that pawn and black's
never going to win
so what i'm seeing is that we would
really love to get a rook on on a1
and it has to be this rook because if we
go rook a8 we relinquish our control
over the b2 pawn so we go rook a5
okay he gives a check on d8 but now we
take the rook and we're upper rook
this one is a classic application of
lpdo first thing i noticed knight on
knight on c6 is loose the king on g8 is
a little bit
airy because he's played f6 so there are
some weaknesses here
which means that we have a very typical
fork against the king in the night
boom problem solved loose pieces drop
off one of the most important
tactical abbreviations that you have to
apply in most positions
okay now here i immediately noticed the
king and
it's also clear to me that because white
is down a piece he's got to do something
essentially immediately
um and if he takes the bishop then black
takes the rook and it's mate so
i noticed that while i cannot give a
check on c8 that square is covered what
i can do is give a preliminary check on
c7
forcing the king to the back rank and
then i go queen c8 with a mate
check sacrificing the queen there once
again notice the x-ray that the rook is
exerting on the c8 square
check checkmate now here it's very
important to avoid
instinct right the instinct is to take
on c8 but take a look at the whole board
what do you see what i see is the queen
bishop battery here
which is a very fearsome battery it's
looking right at the h2 square the h2
square is undefended
which means this is checkmate okay
now this may look like an intimidating
position but really it's not because
look at white's king
white's king has no squares that rook on
g2 is very nicely defended by the pawn
and f3 now is black threatening anything
yes he is
he is threatening to capture on h3 and
deliver checkmate
okay so what's the problem the problem
is that we're in check and all that we
have to do
is find the fastest way to escape the
checks
and the fastest way to escape the check
is is it on the seventh rank no he's got
another check
it's on the fifth rank if we go to f5 he
has no knight checks
and the rook check to b5 simply meets
with a takes b5
he goes that h7 that doesn't actually
help white's cause we simply take the
knight and there's no stopping
okay big deal another check we take it
and we win again this problem very
important to avoid
knee jerk reaction a knee-jerk reaction
is to recapture the rook but guess what
loose pieces drop off and i also noticed
the contact
that the queens are making through the
night which means we need to be thinking
about discover checks
guess what is there a discover check
with the knight there sure is knight g3
check
and free queen okay
so white is down in exchange but what i
immediately notice is that when there's
rooks and and i wanted to say kings but
you know as far as i know black is only
one king
when there's two rooks in a king
clustered together like this and there's
a centralized knight
that means you need to be looking for
forks now if we fork him immediately
it's important to notice that he's
actually just going to take our rook and
at the end of the day he's actually
going to trap the knight as well
so what we want to do is we want to
first take the rook
that brings the king and the rook into a
vulnerable situation where we can now
fork them
and pick off the rook with a winning
pawn and game now these problems
are always tricky for people because
there seem to be no overt
tactics available to white and yet in
fact there
are and the specific tactic is this
concerns this queen on e5 i immediately
see that it's out of squares this move
rook f6
it has actually taken away the queen's
escape route back to black's camp
the queen has no other square so all we
need to do is find a way to attack the
queen
well we can do that with both rooks we
can do rook ae one or rokhafi one but
rogafi one relinquishes control over the
f4 square
so instead we go rook a1 we take the
queen okay
now this one is actually very tricky
and guess what loose pieces drop off
rook on c1 is loose
now i don't know if this tactic is
actually going to exploit the rook but
what i want to make very very clear
is that when you're solving problems or
in general when you're playing
they're you know you want to spend a
large amount of time just
observing just noticing things about the
position
whether or not you're actually going to
end up exploiting them that's a
different
story but you're not going to find stuff
without actually first observing much
like in the scientific method
you need to collect observations first
you know
before you hypothesize about the dead so
we look at the rook on c1 it's weak
is there anything else vulnerable in
black's position well the king sure is
right
because there's no defender surrounding
the king so you know
as many teach us we need to start by
looking at checks captures and threats
now the capture is just absurd because
the bishop is defended
there is a check on e8 and that forces
the king out either onto g7 or h7 but
then combining that with our first
observation about the rook
you might notice that we have this move
queen to b2 swinging the queen onto a
beautiful square
where it is a guard attacking the rook
and b
threatening checkmate on h8 so it's
actually a kind of fork now he goes to
g7 which makes this even more obvious
because it's just a check and we pick
off the book
now here we see that there is
just a mass of pieces clustered on the
king side
and uh we need to make something of that
now the first observation i'm making is
that if the rook on h4 were gone
apologies my voice seems to be cracking
just as i start recording this video
now if the rook were gone we would have
the possibility of delivering a check on
h2 with a queen
unfortunately um as far as i know the
queen can't jump over the rook
but we need to figure out if perhaps we
might be able to
sacrifice the rook in order to pave the
way for the queen and we can do just
that we can give a check on h1
forcing the knight back and then we go
queen h2 check with absolutely
devastating
effect take the knight and the problem
has been solved now
this is one of those problems where you
know it's important not to get
intimidated by
the abundance of pieces that white has
he's got two queens he's got a rook but
look at how many pieces black has on the
king's side we have a simple checkpoint
g2
knight's covering this square queen's
depending upon bingo
this is one of those where you have to
look at the whole board if we look at
the whole board we will see
that black simply has a hanging piece
and a lot of puzzle rush problems just
they get you on your preconception
that it's going to be tricky but
sometimes the problem is actually very
very simple as it is here
bishop is hanging we're just going to
take it and we have one more hurdle to
cross
black attacks tonight now then i can't
move just anywhere because this rook is
going to be lost so the knight has to
move to a square
where it simultaneously guards the rook
is there such a square
there absolutely is next problem
i immediately see the tension between
the two bishops and i also see the fact
that the king is still in the center
whenever the king is in the center
it is particularly vulnerable to various
kinds of
checks um and combining those two
observations we see
that there is a very typical fork on the
bishop
boom boom boom and we're up a piece well
guess what this is
exactly the same problem and you know
what i'm going to amend
this video this is i'm actually going to
do 25 problems
in this video and then 25 problems in
the next etc
um because i think that's just a better
distribution of time this is
you know i i want things to be in
bite-sized pieces so
we're going to end at 25 also my voice
seems to be going
um now we see the bishop on b5
undefended
we see the king on e1 centralized which
means that combining the two together
same exact idea now there's one more
hurdle we can't take the knight
immediately sorry we can't take the
bishop immediately because the knight is
guarding it but
this is where our fiance bishop comes in
we take the knight
and then we take the bishop so what do i
see here
well we gotta look at white's heavy
pieces right in any position
we start by just looking at how our
opponent's pieces are positioned
and whether we can exploit any kind of
latent weaknesses there now we see that
the queen on d3
is vulnerable to an attack by the bishop
right it's on a light square we have a
light square bishop
therefore we go bishop a6 now this
mess might seem intimidating but it's
not and what we have to do is just
unpack the situation for a second he's
attacking our queen we're attacking his
queen
and according to sort of the golden rule
we have to start by looking at the
captures first
so if we take the queen and he takes our
queen
if we take the knight he's gonna take
our bishop but our bishop is also
attacking his rook
so we can actually just take his rook
and then take the knight and we're just
gonna be up a rook
boom okay interesting situation that we
have here
now first thing to notice is white is
down a piece but he's clearly attacking
black's king
by our rule checks captures and threats
there's only one capture rook takes c5
it's not particularly good checks well
there's definitely going to be checks
with a vulnerable king like this
and there's a check on g5 and when the
king moves i notice that that queen on
g5
is actually can combine with a rook to
take on e5
and what's gonna happen then is this
bishop on c5 notice undefended
is actually going to be skewered by the
queen and the rook
in addition to white having a
devastating attack he just takes on e5
so we're gonna take back okay things get
a little bit trickier
i notice the tension between the queens
now if i take the queen he's just gonna
take back and we haven't gained anything
we can win a pawn
but generally as a hint in puzzle rush
problems
the solution always entails winning at
least
two pawns and usually at least a piece
which is the absolute bare minimum in
most problems a lot of the time
it's either checkmate or it's an
overwhelming amount of material
so we have that in our back pocket but
we also have a light squared bishop and
the queen is on a light square i notice
immediately that the queen and the king
are on the same diagonal
noticing that the queen and the king are
on the same diagonal immediately
forces us to think about pins right now
it appears that we cannot
go bishop b5 because the a6 pawn can
simply take the bishop but
combining that with our observation that
the rook on a8 is undefended
which hopefully you've noticed by now as
i've hammered you over the head with
this
we see that we in fact can play bishop
e5 he takes with the queen it's the same
thing we take the queen
and actually not only do we win an
exchange we actually win the other rook
as well
and so we win the game now i see two
things when i look at this problem
first of all i see the back rank the
back rank is weak which means the rook
cannot leave the eighth rank otherwise
he's going to get checkmated
second thing i notice is the tension
that's going on between
white's rook and blackstrap both of them
looking at black's knight
which means that this rook is what's
called overloaded
now as you can probably guess if some if
a piece is overloaded it's doing too
many things at once
you know which is something that i do
very often in real life
the rook is both defending the knight
and defending the king
so if we attack the rook it is not going
to be able to keep doing both at the
same time
is there a way to attack the rook
absolutely now
one more hurdle to cross because he's
counter-attacking r-rook
if we take his rook he takes ours and we
haven't gained anything but
what did i say about knights and kings
in close proximity
that means forks 97 check doesn't work
because he takes with the knight but we
first take on d5
now the knight and the rook the king and
the rook are forkable boom
let's do one more first thing i see the
pawns now
black is down a piece which probably
means we need to operate quickly
the first thing we need first move we
need to look at is a2 check
now a2 check forces the king to move if
it moves to a1
it's clear that we have a check on c2
followed by promotion
if he moves to b2 well then we still
have knight c2
the knight supports the past pawn he
cannot stop promotion because white's
pawn
is simply too far away this is a simple
exercise
in once again starting by looking at
checks check
here now you can't make an omelet
without breaking some eggs we are going
to lose this knight
but we're going to make a new queen and
we ladies and gentlemen are going to
pause here
these were the first 25 problems of
puzzle brush survival of course these
were the easier problems
in tomorrow's video first of all
hopefully my voice will be back and my
apologies for the
the hoarseness but tomorrow we will
solve the next 25 problems and on we
will go until
i hit three strikes i hope that you know
by going slowly i've succeeded in
breaking down some of the things that i
see
some of the ways that i solve these
problems and hopefully i've armed you
with
a couple of tips that you can use to at
least cross the first 25 problems in
puzzle rush
tactify on go solve some problems hope
you enjoyed the video and feel free as
usual
to leave comments and constructive
criticism in the comments below
and i will see you guys in the next
video where we will do the next
25 problems thank you